[Music]
look at the information given on the
screen can you tell me the value of this
integral it will be equal to this we've
seen this result in the previous video
it tells us that integration is just the
reverse of differentiation integral of
the derivative of the function f of X is
just equal to the difference in the
function f of X evaluated at the limits
of integration now in this video we will
understand how to apply this result to
find the integral of a function consider
this function G of X let's find the
integral of this function from A to B
can you think how we can apply this
result to find the integral let's see
suppose we find a function capital G of
X such that its derivative is this
function G of X then we will get the
integral of G of X is equal to the
integral of the derivative of capital G
of X now according to this result we can
see that this integral will be equal to
this so we see that the integral of the
function G of X is equal to the
difference between the values of the
function capital G of X do you know any
such function let's try to find the
function capital G of X so this is what
we have we need to find the function
capital G of X now we have seen earlier
that if we have a function f 1 of X
equal to X then it's derivative is equal
to 1 if we have a function f 2 of x
equal to x squared then its derivative
is equal to 2 times X notice that each
time we take the derivative the power of
X is reduced by 1 now we want the
function whose derivative is equal to X
square
so maybe the derivative of the function
f 3 of X equal to X cubed will give us
this function by now we are familiar
with how to find the derivative of a
function can you find the derivative of
f 3 of x the derivative of f 3 of X will
be given by this limit this is something
we've seen before we know the formula
for the cube of sum of two numbers and
the cube of difference of two numbers
using this here we can easily find that
the derivative will be equal to 3 times
x squared so we get the derivative of X
cubed to be three times x squared but we
want the derivative of this function to
be only x squared ok so what if we
consider the function capital G of X
equal to X cubed over 3 what will be its
derivative now for this function this
average rate will get multiplied by 1
over 3 so we will get the derivative to
be equal to x squared so we get the
function capital G of X to be equal to X
cubed over 3 now to find the value of
the integral we just have to find this
difference but wait what if we add a
constant let's say 1/2 this function
capital G of X what will be the
derivative of the function capital G 1
of X let's continue this in the next
part
so what will be the derivative of the
function capital G 1 of X yes
notice that the function capital G 1 of
X is just the function capital G of X
plus 1 we know that the derivative of a
function tells us its instantaneous rate
of change so adding a constant to a
function will not affect its rate of
change we can find its derivative by
taking the limit of its average rate of
change we will surely get it to be equal
to the derivative of capital G of X so
now we have two functions whose
derivative is equal to the function G of
X that is x squared so what if to find
this integral we use the function
capital G 1 of X instead of capital G of
X notice that since this function is
just capital G of X plus a constant we
will again get that same value for the
integral that means we can use any of
these two functions to find the value of
the integral we found these functions by
going in the reverse direction that is
we started with the derivative G of X
and found the original functions whose
derivative will be G of X so these
functions are called anti derivatives of
the function G of X now let me ask you a
question are there any other anti
derivatives of G of X correct any
function which is equal to G of X plus
some constant will be the antiderivative
of G of X now we can use any of these
anti derivatives to find the integral of
the function we will always get the
value of this integral to be equal to
capital G of B minus capital G of a so
for this reason we denote all these anti
derivatives by one general
antiderivative capital G of X plus a
constant C called the indefinite
integral of G of X
we denoted by the integral symbol
without the limits of integration we can
see that once we know the indefinite
integral we can easily find this
integral the indefinite integral of x
squared is equal to X cubed over 3 plus
a constant C and evaluating it at the
limits of integration we will get this
notice that for this integral we will
get a number as our answer whereas for
the indefinite integral we get a
function so this integral with the
limits of integration is called
as the definite integral let's quickly
review the whole process to find the
definite integral of the function we
first find its indefinite integral now
to find the indefinite integral of the
function G of X we find a function
capital G of X such that its derivative
is equal to G of X and not to find the
definite integral we just have to
evaluate it at the limits of integration
we can see that once we know the
indefinite integral we can find any
definite integral of the function so
usually the indefinite integral is
itself called the integral of the
function so we see that related to a
function we have two types of integrals
indefinite integral and definite
integral now let's see if you can find
the indefinite integral of this function
H of X equal to x squared plus 6 how can
we do that
the indefinite integral of H of X will
be given by a function capital H of X
plus C the function capital H of X
should be such that its derivative is
equal to H of X can you find the
function capital H of X tell us your
answers in the comment section below
and to keep learning such interesting
things
subscribe to our Channel
you